stay consistent is all I'm saying
because because to to the left Trump is
to the left what Hillary is to the right
okay yeah let's just kind of put that
put it there for me if I'm gonna go hard
at someone I have to go hard on the
other one as well that maybe he's on my
side well unless they're not equivalent
oh so so to you so you between the two
I'm assuming the lesser of the two evil
to you is Hillary
man you're not I'm doing facts did
someone ask a leader of a of another
country to conduct a criminal
investigation against the child if you
if we do that I can bring a million and
one different things that Biden has done
and Obama's done and show it to you and
then what are you gonna say so this is a
conversation about give me space on
missile defense and you want to say
that's the same as asking do you want me
to pull up with Biden tool the guy that
here's what we're gonna I want you to
answer the question I just asked you are
you saying this is equivalent or not I I
think every one of them at the same
level if you're asking for a favor that
will do this afterwards it should be
held at the same level I disagree if the
favor is about a diplomatic conversation
that doesn't involve a political rival I
see that as diplomacy now you might not
like the diplomacy but that's not what
so so let me let me ask you this why why
the infatuation with Ukraine all of a
sudden with U.S why
this why why are we why are we all of a
sudden so so Iran on the other end you
know people are there getting killed
plummeted you know they're getting
crushed they're getting destroyed and
our attention is only on Ukraine we're
not thinking about that why are we doing
what we're doing with Ukraine and not
some of the other places you know how
many American people are sitting there
saying oh so when he said that and the
link between the Sun and Ukraine and
himself in the past all this stuff that
pulled up in the New York Post story was
hidden and then afterwards Mark
Zuckerberg said that I was talking to
communication with FBI which he probably
didn't even think he just said that and
then you know the story of Pfizer
announces the uh vaccine is ready three
days after the election is over with all
of this stuff you're sitting there
watching saying listen man I have a hard
time believing what the hell is going on
here now I see what's going on with
Ukraine you have to understand the same
way when you say the conspiracy
theorists from both sides the left's got
its own conspiracies that they follow
like Hillary said the election was a
fraud yeah for three four years all I'm
saying is if you're gonna say that we
have to stay consistent we can only see
we can only see when when people were
saying Trump Russia Russia Russia I said
hey
if you think that's the case prove it I
don't know this recent guy that went
viral Tate who's all over the place do
you know what Tate did I said listen
there's a big difference between you
know breaking the law and offending
people that's good if he offended you
[ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] if you found
I'm offended on a daily basis if he
broke the law that's got to go with the
court I have no control over that I
don't have the investigation so when a
Russia thing took place well Trump Trump
trump Adam Schiff okay if that's the I
don't have access to that do your job
and prove it right that's right and then
three years later Durham comes out this
was adasia paid for Hillary 35 million
American people now you're not no longer
talking about a CNA you just got rip
forgot about Russia and for three and a
half years that's all you guys ever
talked about what happened well you guys
excuse me I'm not you're talking to
Philip no you're not talking you guys
you guys being CNN is what I'm saying
too I'm a contractor for CNN I'm not an
employee I go and speak what I say I
attack president Trump I've said
negative things about Hillary Clinton so
I'm not here as a spokesman for CNN all
I'm saying is all I'm saying is when
you're talking about
uh holding one side to the fire we have
to hold all sides to the fire if we're
gonna do that we have to stay consistent
that's all I'm saying well CNN is
clearly paying the price for having an
agenda and being biased and not holding
both sides accountable I think what you
said is there's there is a major
difference between fact and feelings
right so Trump pissed off a lot of
freaking people that doesn't mean that
he was a criminal I'm not saying that
he's not a criminal that needs to be
proven that's not my job though right my
job isn't to prove that if that's if if
the lady in New York what's her name
Leticia James if if her in New York she
wants to file the lawsuit a quarter of a
billion dollars towards uh Trump and you
know lose license guess what hey it
sucks but guess what you know they can
do that and then you can come back and
make the argument you're gonna have to
spend a lot of money on legal fees so
maybe that's a way of getting them to
spend a lot of money on legal fees and
she did campaign on the fact that if you
elect me I'm gonna sue the Trump family
yeah she kept a promise I mean that's
like you know and there's where but
politicians and and this is one one
problem with the American political
culture where people involved in in
um and civil and criminal cases are
elected politicians who argue for during
a campaign that somebody should be
prosecuted to me is
that's something that should be
borderline illegal suggesting that
somebody whether it's Donald Trump or
Hillary Clinton should be locked up
should be the Judgment of people at the
Department of Justice
those people should be separate as they
are or are supposed to be if you look at
it at Bill Barr for example from the
White House and political pressure we
have gotten way too comfortable in this
country with people saying not only do I
not like my adversary I said this 10
minutes ago but my adversary is an enemy
to America and they should be in in a
jail that's third world lock her up that
is yeah or saying again that the people
who too quickly say Mar-A-Lago he should
he should be charged right well that's a
legal process that should involve fact
by professionals not politicians and I
object to the January 6 committee saying
I want to make referrals they should not
be telling the department like the
Department of Justice doesn't have an
investigation and know how to look at an
investigation in facts as soon as you
make a referral one you're saying
politicians think something should
happen and as soon as the Department of
Justice moves and I don't think the
January 6th committee has thought about
this enough somebody on the right is
going to say you're doing that because
because Congress told you to not because
that's a good case I think January 6
ought to do their own investigation and
say nothing to Department of Justice
Beyond here are some documents if you
want them so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]